hi
[Music]
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain an american survival film called
frozen
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins at a new england ski
resort on mount holliston three friends
namely dan walker joe lynch and dan's
girlfriend parker o'neil have come to
the mountains for a ski trip
dan and joe are childhood best friends
who go on a ski trip every year as a
tradition most of the time joe flirts
with a female ski lift operator to get
cheaper tickets but this time a man
stands in her place the guys make parker
flirt with the operator and get them
cheap tickets while she is at it joe
complains about dan bringing his
girlfriend to a boys only trip it is
evident he is not very fond of parker
she doesn't even know how to ski so joe
thinks it wouldn't be as fun
dan apologizes saying that he thought
bringing her would be okay because they
would get to bond they finally get on
the ski lift and set off for the top of
the mountain on their way joe criticizes
parker for smoking too much making
parker throw an insult back at him dan
is in the middle of the two trying to
handle the situation all of a sudden the
lift stops working people riding them
complain in frustration parker acts calm
but is scared of heights joe makes fun
of her for it while dan tries to console
her eventually the lift continues
working and they reach the top while
skiing dan and joe are unable to have
fun because of parker being slow she
falls down every few minutes annoying
joe even more
at night they are back from the mountain
and are staying in a resort the boys
talk over pizza about the failed trip
joe suggests the two of them catch the
last lift to the hilltop and ski like
they used to parker overhears their
conversation and apologizes for ruining
their trip dan feels bad for her so he
asks her to join them again parker wants
to stay in their room saying she doesn't
enjoy skiing anyway but dan insists so
the three of them repack their gear and
make their way to the left just as they
reach there the operator turns the lift
off he is the same man who parker had
flirted with to get the tickets the
group asks him to let them go one last
time but the man laughs at them saying
they didn't even pay the full price the
first time
moreover the lift is closing because of
a storm so they cannot turn it back on
the operator is absolute about not
letting them go but except when they
offer him an extra hundred dollars the
group sets off on the lift looking at
the people below skiing excitedly
meanwhile a co-worker approaches the
lift operator and tells him about the
next week's schedule the operator
retaliates saying that he will be off
work at his brother's wedding the next
week he leaves the co-worker at the lift
to talk to the manager before leaving he
informs him that three people are still
on the lift so he shouldn't stop it
until they come back
a while after the operator leaves the
man sees three people climbing up the
mountain he assumes that the people are
the ones the operator was talking about
and stops the lift unaware that dan joe
and parker are still on it at first when
the lift stops the group thinks it is
just a minor inconvenience joe yells in
frustration but everyone at the lift
station has already left moreover the
temperature is dropping by the second
making the group shiver in the cold
despite being warmly dressed they talk
about worse ways they could die to keep
them entertained unaware of what is
coming for them they stay there for a
few minutes but start to panic when the
lights go out now they know that the
lift didn't stop because of a
malfunction but someone has stopped it
deliberately they start to yell hoping
someone will hear them parker freaks out
saying that no one knows that they're
here but dan believes that the lift
stopped because of some power outage and
they will be rescued soon the couple
begins to argue in a moment of panic
parker suddenly remembers that it is
sunday and the ski resort won't open
until next friday so if no one comes
looking for them they will be stuck for
almost a week
the friends tell one another that they
will be okay but panic is visible in
their faces
some time later joe has to pee but with
no other way he puts the metal bar up
and pees off the lift parker groans in
disgust while dan stays quiet
then suddenly it starts to snow the
storm that the operator warned them
about hits adding to the group's trouble
some time later a snowplow drives
towards them making the group wave and
yell to get the driver's attention the
driver finally stops the vehicle right
below the group they're relieved to
finally be rescued but it turns out that
man hasn't heard or seen them and he
stopped simply because of the snowstorm
he calls his superior who tells him to
come back quickly so the man turns his
vehicle around while the group screams
at him to stop
unfortunately he cannot hear them
because every character like this in
every movie ever made like this is deaf
they throw their skiing gear at the man
but he doesn't notice them and
eventually leaves
some time later parker takes her gloves
off to smoke but they accidentally fall
off the lift
now the only way out for the group is
for one of them to jump dan volunteers
to do it and believes he will be fine
since the ground is covered in snow
genius
joe tries to stop him saying that they
should wait till the morning but dan is
adamant parker and joe both repeatedly
insist he quit however dan throws his
snowboard to the ground
and jumps off the lift immediately upon
hitting the ground both of his legs are
broken the other two ask him if he is
okay but he only hears mumbling for a
few seconds
dan is horrified to see bones protruding
through both of his knees now there is
no way he can make it down the mountain
to get help
parker throws her scarf at him so he can
use it to stop the bleeding but it lands
on top of a tree
wow these kids are useless
joe then makes a ball out of his scarf
and throws it at his friend it lands
nearby but when dan tries to reach it
the bone protrudes out even more after
tying it around his legs dan asks joe to
pull himself up on the suspension cable
to get to the nearest support tower the
towers all have ladders in them which
joe can use to get downstairs joe
hesitates claiming that he can hardly do
a pull-up but agrees to do it for his
best friend just then they hear growling
nearby a pack of wolves have smelled the
scent of dan's blood and are coming his
way dan freaks out and yells for help
inviting the wolves even more joe gets
on top of the lift but slips back into
it because of the icicles just then a
wolf appears right in front of dan and
growls at him dan stays frozen scared to
do anything parker throws her snowboard
at the animal and makes it go away
however soon he is surrounded by a whole
pack of them dan realizes there is no
way he can survive now he asks joe not
to let parker look down as the animals
surround him joe holds parker's face
crying as the creatures devour dan
sometime later everything goes quiet the
only noise that can be heard is the
howling of wolves in the distance parker
blames joe for asking dan to jump
earlier joe defends himself claiming
that he begged him not to they get into
an argument and start to blame one
another for dan's death in the end they
just hold each other and cry the night
somehow passes as the two fall asleep
parker wakes up in the morning with her
hand around the metal bar which she had
grabbed while asleep she tries to remove
it but her hand is frozen to the bar
she painfully loosens her grip as the
skin of her palm tears off the two have
severe frostbite and cannot survive one
more day on the left joe suggests he try
getting to the support tower again but
parker wants them to wait for a few
hours and see if someone comes looking
for them a while later joe falls asleep
and parker embarrassingly pees on
herself while crying who's gross now
parker when he wakes up the two talk
about different things in their life
joe tells her how he and dan met at
elementary school he claims that since
dan died trying to save them they
shouldn't let his death go to waste joe
then gets on top of their seat again to
try to make it to a support tower this
time the icicles have melted making it
easier for him to move forward however
as he steps on the seat a screw of the
bolt holding the chair to the cable
becomes dangerously loose which makes
the chair rock he somehow manages to get
to the other chair but his palms are
bloodied because of the cable joe still
doesn't give up and climbs up to the
support tower where a single wolf waits
for them on the ground parker throws her
ski pole to the ground to help joe fight
the wolf when he gets there he then
finally climbs down only to be attacked
by the animal however he gets his hands
on the pole and manages to get it off of
him he quickly puts on the snowboard and
heads down the mountain
right behind a pack of wolves follow him
parker asks him to be careful as he
disappears into the mountain now she is
alone in the cold waiting for joe to
return with help however hours pass by
but joe doesn't come back parker knows
that the wolves must have gotten to him
but she still hopes for his safety she
stays there till the following morning
but he doesn't return he must have
bailed on her for ruining the boys trip
parker then moves around the seat making
the bolt move more aggressively
eventually the seat falls to the ground
and lands right on top of her legs
breaking them parker composes herself
and crawls downhill on the snow after a
while she comes across the horrifying
scene of joe's remains before she can
react parker notices a wolf in the front
but since the creature is full after
devouring joe it doesn't attack her
parker somehow makes it to the side of
the road and lies there waiting for help
eventually a person brings her in their
car and drives away
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching